τι είχε γίνει βεβαίως μπορι κάποι άλλι που ήταν εκεί και περιμένα στο σπίτι να
ήξεα όταν το αίμα θα βεβαίωσ ήταν κάτι που δεμπορούσανφανδαστο ότι θα ιζούσαμια τέτοια κατάσταση
συναντίσατε μετά αυτούς που λένε πως είναι πίσω από αυτά που έμαόχιοχίου δεν ποτε ωστόσο
είστε μοναχοπαίδι ίσως ήταν και αυτός ένας από τους λόγους και ροαδοπουλού που επιλά επιλέξατε
αγάτ μια μεγάλη οικογένεια μπορεί ναι ναι ιότι πάντοτε ήθελα να είχα αδέλφεια υτιχώσι τιχα
αρκετά εξαδέλφια χ έτσι καιμούν συντεδεμένι μεταμετα εξαδέλφια μου ναι ήταν ανας λόγος πάντοτε έλεγα
θα ήθα λα να είχα τε ένα ναδελφό είτε μια αδελφή νομίζω ότι εναι κάτι
σημαντικό στη ζωήσου ι δικά μα φεύγουν και οη γωνίσου να έχεις κάποιον στανισα ένανάνθωπο
τελείως δικόου αλλά δυστυχώς δεν το ίχα αλλά είμαι πολύ συντεδεμένοι όπω σας είπα μεταξαδέλφια
μου και τώρα βεβαίως με τα παιδιά μου που είναι μεγάλο στήριγμα γι μένα σε
ότι αφορά το το όνομα λεβέντη μεγαλώσατε με κάποιες γραμμές και να βαβαδο πούλου λόγο
και του ονόματος του πατέρα σας μεγάλος α νομίζω μια είχαμια φυσιοδολογική ζωή ήμουν και
στο ικοτοφείο ια κάποια χρόνια αλλάσίγουρα είμασταν πολύ πιο και δεημόνο έγουμε αλλά η εποχεί
εκείνη τα πολύ πιο αυστη γρονείς από ότι είμαστα εμείς καιείναι η γωνς τορα ακόμα
λίγοτεο τι θυμάστε από τον πατέρα σας ήταν κάποιος παρά πολύ έξυπνος που δούλευε πάρα
πολύ αλλά που κατάφερε εκτός από το βεβαίο